so mr. Tully said this project could be
about any biology topic we're interested
in and it could be a research paper or
an illustration or a video or something
so class here's my video it's about some
of you so pay attention I'm overweight
and it's obviously a hard thing to deal
with for all sorts of reasons but the
biggest problem I've been having
recently is not about me personally it's
everyone else
it's how everyone else sees me and
treats me just because I'm overweight
and all of you might assume things about
me about all fat people that probably
aren't true
[Music]
so my project is talking about these
myths about weight and Prejudice and
getting some actual facts out there you
know how mr. Tully assigned this project
like a month and a half ago well for the
last month and a half I've been bringing
this camera to school in here just like
this so it picks up pretty much
everything you've said so don't be
surprised if you hear yourself in this
video
here's a little snippet from Arthur and
mr. Tully Feinberg three weeks ago
hey banging would you get on the cell
quiz and 83 he would have thought
someone so many cells would have done
better as you all know we'll be hearing
much more from Arthur and we'll see if
he can top that and we'll see if Tully
does anything about it like a good and
caring teacher would and now I present
the statistics in the past 20 years
obesity in children and adults has
doubled in that same time obesity in
teenagers has tripled now what am I
supposed to do when I hear those numbers
I don't know
those statistics are really scary but I
don't think about obesity like that all
I know is it I have to deal with a bunch
of stereotypes and prejudices every day
all over the place and at school I get
picked on I'm not going to pretend it
isn't harmful because it is rose just
even legal let's get my lawyer there
King for 20 yeah what's the camera their
faces that I've enjoyed just because I'm
heavy
other people assume I'm lazy stupid mean
unpopular and that I eat too much but
stereotypes aren't the truth they're
mean and annoying but most of all wrong
you
these are the genes that are responsible
for things like eye color skin color
being left-handed or right-handed
does it affect being fat some people say
that there's genes that affect clearly
it's not genes
it's Twinkies or pancakes I figure out
doing nothing
all right cream with gravy on it I'm
gonna have to call a foul on that
Twinkie comment Arthur said it but you
mr. Tully you've been teaching biology
for years and I thought maybe you'd have
the facts well let's find out what the
causes of obesity are from you know
experts the causes of obesity are very
complex it is a combination of genetic
factors environmental factors
psychological factors and it's important
to recognize that so that when we look
at someone and we see whatever their
body weight is we don't make assumptions
about their behaviors based on that
information whoa that's weird that
expert researcher with a PhD just said
that Twinkie thing was wrong let's
double check it's not cheese its
Twinkies genetic factors environmental
factors psychological factors right of
course if someone just sits around and
eats miles and miles of Twinkies all day
they'll gain weight but I don't just sit
around and I don't eat junk food
maybe the causes of obesity are very
complex the causes of obesity are very
complex
you gonna keep sitting in front of that
camera at the end of time no just until
the tape runs out the project is doing a
week and I haven't even added graphics I
haven't even done anything
[Music]
so coming back to that if we looked
around this room you just you see lots
of different body shapes and sizes so
lots of different diets then you may
remember he singled out two of us me and
my friend Erica so someone like Erica
probably had a pretty healthy breakfast
this morning
somebody like Benny I don't know
probably had pancakes again god no I had
toasted an apple oh you mean an apple
pie look what my partner is trying to
say is that having a healthy diet and
staying active and exercising there's
the really the only things that are
keeping you from having a normal body
and done right just look at Erica okay
two things one I've been pally with
Erica since like the second grade and
she spends a whole lot of time eating
junk food and watching TV and she's
still like a size zero myth
Erica eats nothing fact Erica when a pie
income test two years ago yes fact she
did win a pie-eating contest can you not
I'm trying to make a point okay one
erica has a crazy diet
- here's my morning routine I get up
early I have an apple or banana and some
OJ we post and then I take Buddhist
pearl walk just as leisurely stroll then
I get ready and head to school and have
to hear stuff like this it's not James
and he's our ice cream with gravy on it
pancakes are sitting around doing
nothing it's complicated healthy diet
and exercise are important but they are
going to make me shrink and I gain more
but exercise in the shrink way and I've
gained more weight if I ate what Erica
does if I'm eating healthy and staying
active then I'm probably in better shape
than Erica just because someone's skinny
it doesn't mean anything
look here's another doctor we talked to
parents about healthy lifestyles we find
that one of the biggest misconceptions
they have is that equating being thin
with being healthy or being obese with
being unhealthy and that's just not
necessarily the case there's a lot more
that determines obesity besides what
kinds of foods you eat what kinds of
physical activity you do or sedentary
behaviors you do a lot of it is familiar
or genetic and really outside of the
child's control and so the important
thing is to always value health over
appearance as a tough geometry test
hey Erica would you do for your pet pain
to school
Arthur why are you breathing does your
sister know you have her hoodie shut up
let's clarify what happened there Arthur
and Meghan walked by and called me a pig
a pet pig actually
[Music]
Arthur and others are clearly prejudiced
against overweight people and there
aren't any scientific facts to back them
up one of mr. Tully said something like
people with blue eyes usually have lower
IQs than everyone else it's true if you
see someone with blue eyes you should
just assume they're dumb and ugly if
everyone thought that people with blue
eyes even if they were really smart
would start to feel pretty bad about
themselves hearing all the name-calling
and laughing behind their back you know
hey bluey generally people view
blue-eyed people as stupid mean ugly
lazy and unpopular that seems pretty
ridiculous
having mean thoughts about somebody for
being the way they are and looking the
way they do it's childish it's ignorant
I just need it for the next two periods
today the ones you've been wasting it
I'm not wasting it I think I'm actually
getting Megan's ego on camera that shows
up as an evil aura wouldn't it be easier
to sear that cake on your thighs
you can stop carbo-loading now how many
lunch periods you have um you're always
I think that may be a problem she's
having a salad she shouldn't be having
anything at all she looks like a pig
turn it off John you need this this is
why you're bringing it to school I'm not
turning it off
they're just mean the
you're not a pig
maybe we're right No
people make fun of me all the time
because I thought and I just put up with
it you're gonna be alright it's not like
this hasn't hasn't happened before
yeah I know Thanks
if you go to the nurse and say a pink
guy you can get out of here
I didn't go to the nurse and lie to her
and go home I sucked it up and went to
gym and guess what happened there I got
teased in the locker room and when we
were picking teams for soccer Jen Martin
called me thunder thighs I scored a goal
though but no one seemed to care you
know that skill in the locker room last
year we all got weighed in a big group
for some reason and miss Keane and skip
my name on the list and wave me after
everyone was gone she thought she was
being nice I guess but it turned into
this whole joke where they said they
couldn't use that skill because it
didn't go up high enough I showed a lot
of name-calling and ridicule
but sometimes it's when people don't say
anything that hurts the most people
deliberately look away from me when I
pass them in the hallway
it's like if we make eye contact or say
hi to each other I'll make them gain a
hundred pounds on the spot what I'm
saying is it's not just the teasing
that's the problem
bias and prejudice against people with
thunder thighs is something that's
automatic someone sees a fat person
someone sees me and they already have me
pegged they already know everything
about me and what they want to think of
me and what I have to live with every
day is knowing that people automatically
think less of me
weight bias has a range of negative
consequences and students who are teased
or victimized because of their weight
are vulnerable to depression anxiety low
self-esteem and poor body image all of
which can take a considerable toll on
emotional well-being
in addition way bias can increase
vulnerability to unhealthy eating
behaviors and avoidance of physical
activity both of which may reinforce
additional weight gain and obesity it
seems like the prejudice does a lot of
harm do you really want to hurt someone
like that for all those mean jokes funny
enough for my depression and stress and
anxiety to be worth it
it hurts it still does because every
time I'm in biology around Arthur who
thinks it's okay to make fun of me and
around Tully who just doesn't care I'm
constantly reminded that people don't
respect me why because I have more fat
cells in them which by the way I don't
have total control over there are
biological and genetic contributors to
body weight which people do not have
total control over
I wish there was an easy solution to
this problem I wish that people weren't
so superficial and that the prejudices
and biases or whatever you want to call
them just didn't exist I guess you just
got to realize that people are different
and that's probably the coolest thing
about people as a whole discriminating
because of weight is just as ignorant
and mean as discriminating because of
skin color or gender girls right
and I'm sure Arthur made fun of Dave
because he's in a wheelchair I mean mr.
Tully just let it happen all the time be
on the news or something yeah
and I'm sure that everyone who bullies
fat people know someone who's fat that
they would never try to put down yeah I
know you mean you said braces remember
oh yeah when I first met you yeah you
know remember Donny O'Malley used to go
on my bus used to brutalize me call me
things like train tracks until I just
decided not to take the bus anymore well
I mean I know you mean and I know how
ridiculous it is so you were picked on a
lot yeah one day I just yelled him
scared the heck out of him maybe that's
what you should do just freak out our
friend Megan get a megaphone and a
soapbox and start a riot against your
prejudice I don't think starting a riot
would do anything it would get me a
detention and and probably a court date
but it wouldn't really teach Arthur or
Megan anything I'm just saying don't
knock fat people because it's just
terribly mean and nasty and vicious and
lousy and rotten sucked fat
so class I'd like to conclude my project
with what I've learned in the past month
or so doctors seem to have their ducks
in a row about this whole diet and
exercise thing I eat well and I exercise
I'm doing the best I can with the body I
have everyone's body is different the
science behind it is complicated I get
the same thing as any of you and our
bodies will respond differently
I'm worried some of you might be putting
gravy on your ice cream they was looking
for that keeping friends around when
you've got the bruise helps a lot there
were some days when Arthur was on a roll
that just got to me and glad I have John
and Erica around and walk the dog I did
already and my family they're good to
talk to you because they listen and they
don't call me fatty or tubs like some
people at school it does hurt to be
teased but what sort of person does that
they don't know how much it really
affects me it's at least enough for me
to spend a whole lot more time that I
needed to on this project well that's it
I think I've cleared up some myths about
overweight people I've secretly recorded
a classroom and I've said some not so
nice things about the teacher greeting
this whoops
you